Netflix is adding a bunch of awesome
content in july 2019 and getting rid of
a lot of great titles too here are our
picks for the movies you have to stream
one more time before they leave the
service in the mood for something
swinging shagadelic and downright groovy
Netflix subscribers have until July 1st
to catch Mike Myers of the bug tooth to
babe obsessed a British spy Austin
Powers in the first two films of his
action comedy franchise Austin Powers
international man of mystery sent us on
a stitch Allah spy as he wakes up in
1997 after spending 30 years on ice
following an assassination attempt by
dr. evil also played by Mike Myers dr.
evil soon concocts a plan to hold a one
hundred billion dollar ransom over the
world what comes next is a string of
silly antics evil henchmen beautiful
Fembots a generation exim with serious
daddy issues a doomsday device and
plenty of James Bond gags
The Spy Who shagged me takes everything
fans loved about the first film then
adds a clone a time-traveling VW Beetle
a Scottish guard and a volcano lair into
the mix if laughter is what you're after
an Austin Powers double feature is just
the thing for you
the dark fantasy drama from Academy
award-winning director Guillermo del
Toro Pan's Labyrinth made it into
countless best of year lists when it
opened to sweeping acclaim in 2006 in
the 13 years since its release the film
was been regarded as one of the greatest
movies of all time and the best of del
Toro's illustrious career set in Spain
in the summer of 1944 the film follows
Ophelia a young girl who discovers that
she may be the living being carnation of
a royal whose father ruled the
underworld one evening a philia follows
an insect she believes to be a fairy
into a labyrinth where she meets the
faun of being who toss her with three
missions she must complete in order to
become a mortal and live in the
underworld as a princess Pan's Labyrinth
leaves Netflix at the end of June so
went to the maze and discover its magic
before it's too late if you have yet to
see director Jonathan Demi psychological
horror film July 1st it's your last
chance to do so on Netflix
The Silence of the Lambs an adaptation
of Thomas Harris's 1988 novel of the
same name follows ambitious young FBI
trainee Clarice Starling as she builds a
relationship with imprisoned cannibal
serial killer dr. Hannibal Lecter
she needs his advice to catch another
insane serial killer Buffalo Bill within
cold walls of the Baltimore State
Hospital for the criminally insane
Clarice offers personal information to
Hannibal in exchange for clues on the
identity of Buffalo Bill and how she
might apprehend him one of the top
grossing movies of 1991 the winner of
multiple Academy Awards a critical and
commercial success and a film preserved
in a National Film registry The Silence
of the Lambs of the cinema classic and
the linchpin of the thriller genre they
miss watching it from the comfort of
your couch while you still can
there's no telling what dr. Lecter might
do otherwise a census taker once tried
to test me I ate his liver with some
fava beans and a nice Chianti if you're
suffering from a serious case of Keanu
Reeves fever you'll want to watch the
Matrix trilogy before Netflix clears her
films from its content library first to
dig into 1999 s the matrix featuring
Reeves as computer programmer Thomas
Anderson who hides a double life as a
hacker named neo when he meets Morpheus
Neos reality is forever changed after he
discovers that the reality he knows is
completely fabricated neo realizes that
he's been trapped in the matrix a system
that prevents a false reality to its
victims and feeds off their minds of
bodies once your brain has been
thoroughly blown by the matrix dive
deeper into the stylish world with the
Matrix Reloaded and the Matrix
Revolutions James Cameron's 1984 sci-fi
flick the Terminator is a sensual
viewing for anyone who loves cyborg
assassins Arnold Schwarzenegger Bice
takes time travel and bombastic action
sequences it's also a required watch
leading up to the premiere of November's
Terminator dark fate as if you don't
know already the film features watcher
Nagar as an Android sent from the Year
2029 to 1984 Los Angeles to kill Sarah
Connor he'll eventually become the
mother to the man destined to save
humankind from a sentient artificial
intelligence system known as Skynet
meanwhile a human soldier from the
future Kyle Reese risks everything to
protect Sarah from being terminated
whether you're reliving the action or
witnessing it for the first time
catching the Terminator on Netflix
before it leaves in July should be at
the top of your to-do list because it's
going faster la vista baby
Vince Vaughn and Owen Wilson starred
wedding crashers as best birds and
partners in crime who have perfected the
art of crashing weddings and willing
women in a hilarious montage the film
quickly chronicles appears most
successful wedding season ever then
brings the audience's up to speed on
their riskiest mission yet
sneaking into the wedding of a daughter
of the US Secretary of the Treasury
featuring more one-liners that we can
quote here and an absolutely hysterical
performance by Will Ferrell wedding
crashers as he epitome of r-rated
mid-2000s comedies check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the best movies on
Netflix are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]